what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
from the brilliant g.o.m films
toby maguire reacting to spider-man no
way home trailer i love these and look
it says dub in the title of this a lot
of people are like oh i thought this was
really i already know some of those
comments are coming in i'm like just
you just read this
it says it
three letters that's a simple concept it
says there's not a whole lot else it
means anyway
let's get into action because these
videos are hilarious we had to do a few
of his before if you haven't seen his
channel before trust me some of them are
just so darn funny and uh he's been such
a great support to our channel as well
so thank you for uh you even emailed
this our way so i'm like oh thanks for
watching snow man let's get into it
i'm really excited to watch the trailer
to know you're home
i'm also excited when it's pizza time
i knew this was coming not true
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people but
this isn't about me this is hurting a
lot of people
hey where's harry he was the best
[Laughter]
oh my god
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry
bother you sir please i didn't have
super friends back
in my day i had to carry the whole
franchise
i forgot the part and that's my problem
i forgot that's my problem what's that
uncle ben right
peter should take your advice but you're
not tony stark
that's a lot
bitterness is about to forget the peter
the
of
parker spider-man
everyone yeah in fact i wish that uh i
could forget that you played them oh god
very intense
yep it's dirt
lizard electro sand man and green goblin
are back
cool
cool
cool
hey he looks familiar where is he from
okay the only reason why i watched this
trailer is because i thought that i
was gonna be in
okay
it's not hard
i am spider-man
i am
[Laughter]
get the dog get the pizza i love how he
managed to maintain this like bitter
cocky attitude
i'm the classic spider-man i don't even
have to look half the time with this he
even managed to throw in like references
to the quotes dirt in your eyes bringing
up uncle ben oh that dig at uh i didn't
have super friends when i was doing it
and i have the rest of the mcu on my
back because this works so well on so
many levels because we're all expecting
tobey maguire to be in this movie i
firmly believe 100 000 that he is indeed
in this film so it's working on that
level of him watching it making fun of
the fact that he's not actually in the
trailer and that joke too of like uh
holarism watches because i thought i
would beat it he's the og tim mcguire
has always seemed like like these days
especially like just tired and done with
hollywood
so having just want to make art just
want to make art i barely work anymore
because it's my choice to barely work
anymore i love it i love it it has this
like truly fantastic meta quality on so
many layers it really feels like you're
going on a small character journey like
i i love the way that you chose the
footage because so much of the time he's
not even looking at the screen yeah it
really enhances that sort of like
reminiscing to the glory taste and
feeling yeah bitter about that i don't
even want to look but at the same time
like i could show this kid up in a snake
yeah like yeah i just took on a nice
little life about it the comments about
the pizza time too oh so good it's so
good perfectly i love like the laugh
that i mean you have that laugh for all
these like personalities that you're
making fun of when you're doing this but
the laugh here especially just works
that much better another well done video
man it's videos killing it in views as
expected i appreciate the support you've
been showing us and uh i hope more
people i hope you sort of a million
subscribers as soon as possible because
you take a lot of work you know you
gotta fight i i know this interview is
from collider
so you have to like find the right
moments to match these lines and you put
in the extra attention to detail to
making sure you could have like the
references to the spider-man movies and
the spider-man quotes instead of just
saying like random stuff so yeah thank
you dude for everything you've been
doing guys subscribe to gom films if you
haven't done so already subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell like many channels we'll be
covering spider-man no way home yeah
some of you already sick of it before
the trailer came out we'll get ready to
get even sicker because we got so much
more to talk about and dissect that
second trailer and then there's even
more to dissect and talk about
guys we'll see you soon
[Music]